THREE, ZERO AND ONE.
BOTH ON THE MINUTE MARKN
D.C. COLEMAN ON THE  TO
THE FIVE M ATTACK.
HAN NAPIN FOR LUKIC.PS
GOING AND HATHAWAY
GIVING
GAUDREAU WILL TRY IT
AGAIN AND GETS TO A
FRONT OF THE NETS AND
GAUDREAU GETS IT AND
NOT N DETROIT
AND WATCH OUT FOR
LINDHOLM.
TRYING TO GET OF THE LA
THREE YEARS AND IT
LOOKS LIKEEER
OVERALL.
HE GOT HIS WIN
SEVERAL YEARS S ELSE IS
PUSH THROUGH ENOUGH
AS HE RIPS OFF
GAUDREAU DOORSTEP
THIS IS CRITICAL.
STRONG, SCHILLINGTON
THE SEAS PARTED AND
HE SKATED DOWN THE
WING OPINION OVECHKIN
SKATES THIS IS A
CRITICAL KILL FOR THE
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT
ON SPORTS WASHINGTONNGS.
HOW MANY READY FOR THIS
HANIFIN.
AND RASMUS ANDERERO COV
VERY IMPORTANT TO HIS
DOCTOR VERY IMPORTANT
INTO AWAITING
DEFENDER.
LEWIS SPRINKLES THIS
WITH GOOD LOOKS FOR
HIS LINE.
>>
SPORTS WASHINGTON.
14 SECONDS REMAIN.
HANIFIN CAREFULLY
HIM.
YOU GOT TO WATCH HIM ITT
SUDDEN VICTORY